it's been a wild season of The Bachelor
and the women tell all special will
address everything I was at the taping
and Ben Higgins revealed just how on
edge he was who are you most nervous to
see of the women all of them last time I
saw these women I was saying goodbye to
him so I was really nervous I was I was
walking down there thinking you know I
last time I met like had seen his woman
my heart was torn sometimes I was if
some of the hardest decisions I've ever
had to make in my life
so to see them again just kind of
reminds me of those moments you know is
rough another person dreading that day
the infamous Olivia I think nervous was
an understatement I was freaking out all
day but the ladies did compliment Ben
for being a great bachelor they were so
kind to me so supportive you'll see it
all the women go after each other more
than anything I even saw Jubilee wiping
her eyes in the bathroom at one point
during the taping
you seemed emotional being kind of
confronted by the other women some
things that I say people don't take the
right way or the you know they get
offended by coming out here I felt like
I had a lot to answer to and I knew it
was gonna you know I knew I was gonna be
put on the spot and there's gonna be
people coming from me so yeah it was
hard The Bachelor women tell all airs
Monday on ABC